I just have to start with uh what is it
like being married to Ben wall Blanc
well is that I was with the can now what
I mean uh I'll save that part for later
almost I'll air it after but yeah I've
never seen Glass Onion yeah I guess it's
in the cinemas now yeah exactly it is
true I'm married to James Bond
oh [ __ ] man I didn't know that yeah yeah
are you credited in the phone I don't
know I've seen it
I don't really know why they wanted to
do it but anyway I thought Knives Out
one was brilliant and so yeah so why not
I turn up a few hours
look at your nails you're trying to
deflect from talking about get your
nails on camera
your hardcore sort of no absolutely no
oh you were saying no that's actually
not what are you rock and roll first of
all look we're deflecting on to me and
we need to talk about the two of you
people want to know more about you no
they don't they want to talk they really
want you to be talking yes 100 so let's
get into it right exactly let's start
let's rock a ball so my question for you
both is that you were at San Diego
Comic-Con to promote the movie and now
you're here in Brazil for ccxp was it in
your contract did you demand that you
would go to the biggest comic-cons in
the world and speak in front of
thousands of people because I mean you
needed to have it in the contract yeah
yeah for my for my ego basically just uh
yeah
adoring people clapping when you walk
out on stage is always a good feeling do
you actually enjoy like do you get do
you enjoy going in front of like 5 000
people and talking or is there like are
you really nervous as you're stepping
out there it's about the closest thing
you can get to feeling like you're uh
like you're uh I don't know AC DC or
something it's it's really fun to walk
out on the stage and people are excited
to listen to you talk about a film you
made is pretty pretty cool pretty cool
QQ doesn't like it I think I think I do
rather like it yeah I think I do it
worries me how much I like it you were
kind of a big deal in San Diego the you
know well I was terrified that because
they bring their actors out one by one
and I I'm so old now passe and I thought
you know they'll bring out Chris Pine
I'll go mad they'll bring out the others
I go mad and then they'll say Hugo they
love you but I think they're on crack or
something no it's because you were
dropping all those things about s m and
Dungeons and there was only one person
at that convention who really loved me
and he was dressed for the whole three
days as a hot dog
and he followed me wherever I went I
couldn't shake him
do you remember the Hot Dog I was
terrified I still have nightmares about
him I know I think he wanted to rape me
that's pretty great wanted to read
listen I think the footage for this
movie looks fantastic the trailer looks
great it looks so much fun and I think
the main reason I'm also so excited is
John and Jonathan I think they're both
such talented filmmakers and can you
sort of talk about working with them and
what they brought to this movie and and
you know what I mean because they're
they're both very talented they are very
I mean first of all they're funny really
funny guys and they have a history
making really great comedy
um they have good hearts and the the
their idea for how they wanted to tell
the story for at least for me was
exactly what I like about big budget
filmmaking which is you know not too
cool for school there's an Earnest real
heart to it with a really sweet message
the comedy is really on point the visual
practical element is is was really neat
I think you know especially nowadays
with all the green screen to do stuff
practically with real monsters made by
super Craftsman and effects on set that
you can feel and touch and interact with
um and they're they are technicians
they're I mean it takes a real Samurai
mind to figure out how to shoot a film
of this size and scope and you could
feel them wanting to knock it out of the
park having come from you know their
last phone was uh shoot a film of them a
third of the the size and scope of this
and you could feel them really wanting
to to win so I like their ambition too
yeah and it I think
maybe what I responded to most in their
script
was that it's about losers I you know
this little band of
comrades they're all a bit crap
you know you're not great at being a
Bard no and the magician
played by
um Justice is really bad what do they
call magicians and Dungeons and Dragons
I think it's sorcerer sorcerer he's not
much good
and uh Michelle's character has been
thrown out of whatever what is she
barbarian barbarian and uh he's still in
love with a uh her husband who is in
love with someone else and I I responded
to that loser-ish thing about these uh
this little band I found maybe that's
the English
predilection we love a loser and that no
no need to stop I'm just going to say
really enjoy being in Brazil and
definitely take out your phones when
you're walking out on that stage have a
fantastic afternoon